let's just get your opinion you know on
children now being included
in the pfizer clinical trial and soon to
be moderna
it's clearly important we know that
children
can get coronavirus they can get
covet disease they can get this unusual
complication of cova disease that goes
by its initials misc
they can transmit the disease to even
more vulnerable people
so it's critical that we have the
ability if we really want to get to this
thing that we like to call herd immunity
that we can actually immunize children
and we can
cannot and shouldn't do it until
children have been studied
how would them having a specific vaccine
for their age group
help end the pandemic i guess we know a
lot
about viral diseases in general it goes
back to smallpox it includes polio it
includes a bunch of other viral diseases
and some bacterial diseases and we know
what it takes
to really eliminate a disease worldwide
for example
smallpox has been eliminated polio
with two countries i can't remember
where they are right now
has been eliminated we could achieve
that actually with measles if we could
get
everyone who should be vaccinated
vaccinated with the measles vaccine
we therefore have a pretty good basis of
information to say if we can achieve a
certain
level of people in the population who
get
the vaccine for covid against the
coronavirus
that we would be able to eliminate that
disease
and that's critical we obviously don't
right now have any medications that
treat it particularly well
we don't really know a lot about its
long-term consequences you've heard
about long-haulers
we don't know about um children and
young adults there's a percentage of
them for example that get what's what's
known as myocarditis where they get an
inflammation of their heart muscle
we don't know how many children and
young adults are at risk for that we
don't know what the long-term
consequences are for that
there was just today an article i looked
at that
demonstrates that the virus pretty
easily gets into brain tissue
so we don't know what the long-term
consequences of covet in your brain is
if you're say a four-year-old so
um these are the sorts of reasons we
need to put an end to the virus as a
pandemic
parents are hesitant what would you say
to them to
maybe ease their mind a bit on having
their child get a covenant vaccine
there are two pieces one is that by the
time we really
have a pediatric vaccine whether it's
actually the same vaccine
in the same dose or a slightly modified
dose
we will know what the side effects and
the long-term effects
middle term effects i guess i would say
of of either the
pfizer-based vaccine and the
merdana-based vaccines are
right now there have been between the
two probably 80
000 people who have gotten one or the
other of those vaccines
and the side effect profile is
remarkably
safe um a few people get aches and pains
and that's a
good thing it's like the lousy taste of
cod liver oil right if it didn't taste
lousy we didn't think it would work who
knows what god liver oil is
at any rate the um the issue
is when we have a safe vaccine and we
have a vaccine
if it turns out to be in the real world
as effective as either one of those
vaccines was
in the trial then the first thing is how
do i know i'm doing my child good the
answer is because you're preventing
a really bad disease the second thing
and people would say this for measles as
well and this would be my response
is that we know that a subset of people
who get
measles or who get coveted children
have horrible outcomes there are
children who have died from covid there
are
children who die from measles those are
totally preventable deaths
and you might say to me as a parent but
it's only one in
eight hundred thousand and i would go
right but i can't tell you if your child
is going to be that one in 800 000 and
you have a way to eliminate that risk
and make it
zero and that's to me the compelling
logic
we can't very well in the medical field
take
population statistics and apply it to an
individual
if we know that 90 plus percent of
children who get coveted get over it
that's great but we don't know who's in
the 7 to 10 percent who don't get over
it and that's
that's the challenge studies of new
drugs
and new vaccines when they're
appropriate for adults are done in
adults first i'm fine with that
but then they are hardly ever done in
children and then as a pediatrician who
needs to use those medications or
needs to vaccine to immunize rather an
important
subset of the population in a large
subset of the population you need to
know
i need to be able to look a parent in
the eye and go i'm comfortable that this
is a safe vaccine and it's going to be
effective and without
studies of children that's very hard to
do
from your professional standpoint when
do you realistically think that we could
be getting a vaccine for kids what do i
believe what do i hope what i really
hope
is that we get it in time for the next
academic year so by
next august so that we can do
large-scale immunization of children
even if we do it in the schools that
would be a start can we
can we achieve that boy i don't know
um and i'm not saying that in a negative
way i think we can
because we've this has been the fastest
development
and efficacy and safety testing of a
vaccine in the history of
of human immunology and human
immunization science it's amazing to me
how quickly this
has happened and
i think we can do it there are certain
things by the way because of the speed
we don't know
but we know about as much
for the for the pfizer and the modern
vaccines as we know for most other
vaccines when they come online
the the important thing we actually
don't know that we would know if it had
played out over its usual
oozing out of of vaccine studying and
approval
is whether or not if i get the vaccine
and then i get exposed to covid what
hang out in my nose and can i spread it
to other people
we know how infectious you are or are
not in most cases if you get
other vaccines we actually don't know
that yet we'll know it by next year but
we don't know it yet for the covet
vaccines
that would be the sort of thing that
would have
been known if we took the usual
leisurely approach to vaccine
development that
that we didn't have the luxury of doing
this time between
now and that potential approved vaccine
for kids whether it's before next school
year or in 2022 whenever it is
what you parents need to do between now
and then to keep their
family safe it's going to be a number of
challenges
and then i'll get to the meat of your
question if you think about
trying to get enough vaccine out to all
of the people who need the vaccine in a
timely fashion
when we'll be able to get through that
whole process and when we'll feel
comfortable that enough even adults have
been vaccinated that's very hard to
predict it's totally dependent on the
supplies and then
just the logistics of getting the
vaccine out and into the community and
getting everybody vaccine
and getting everybody immunized and then
having them remember both of these
the pfizer and modern vaccines require
two shots and so
getting everybody in for that second
shot and keeping track of it
i mean you know if you think we need 350
million
people immunized we need twice that many
doses
the science and the and the the ability
to develop that is there
but it's a big challenge to get that all
distributed and then get to the people
who
for a bunch of reasons don't like to
deal with the healthcare world so
so we have those hurdles so that means
that there will be a lot of
people still at risk for the next
five or six months and we have to do
what we know works for this
for this virus we have to wear masks we
have to wash our hands
we have to socially distance when when
people have been looking now in the the
more recent studies about
transmission of disease people who've
been doing case tracking they seem
now to largely go back to smaller groups
so those are in your home those are in
places like
restaurants where you've been there for
a while those are bars those are
unfortunately places of
houses of worship where you start there
for a long time and you may be singing
or
speaking loudly as part of the of the
prayer service
we need to figure out ways to deal with
those appropriately
hand washing social distancing trying to
avoid those small crowds
the other thing i think parents can do
by way of
advocacy but also just plain information
the other thing that we know
is that one of the simplest ways to
deal with minimizing transmission for
people who need to be indoors is to have
exchange of fresh air
it's easy to say if you live in
minnesota right now you don't open your
windows if you live in
in las vegas in july you don't really
want to open your windows but we
can we can figure out if you're a parent
you can ask your school
what steps they've taken to try to
increase air exchange
in the school rooms in the classrooms
during the course of the day
those those will probably wind up
costing a little bit more money because
it'll cost more to cool more or heat
more i get it
but air exchange is crucial and and
older buildings
probably very old buildings probably
leak but there's an era where buildings
were incredibly tight windows didn't
open
parents need to investigate what's being
done to ensure that the air is being
refreshed in some
reasonable way is there anything else
that you want to add that you think is
really important to get across
maybe something i didn't ask about that
you'd like to share
well you know there's still a certain
amount of covert denial
right now and that's unfortunate i think
i think
we've long since reached the point of
recognizing that this is a very real and
very lethal disease and people need to
respect the fact that it
infects a lot of people it infects a lot
of people in very odd ways
and even people who are healthy enough
to get over the acute illness a
percentage of those still seem to be
suffering long-term symptoms and so this
is a very real
disease with consequences that we don't
fully know
because it's only been about a year
since it was first described in the
chinese population so we
we don't know a lot about the long-term
consequences i can tell you i would
rather not have covet knock on wood so
far i have not
i don't want to get that disease i don't
know enough it's
i'd feel different if i got pneumonia i
know we can
treat certain bacterial pneumonias viral
pneumonias will get better i don't know
the long-term consequences
if i got coveted and got over it
whatever that means would i really be
over it